to get a better intuition for the price
elasticity of demand i thought i would
take a look at some of the more extreme
cases and think about what types of
elasticities of demand we would see so
this right over here is a vial of
insulin many many diabetics not all
diabetics but many diabetics need to
take insulin daily they need to inject
it in order to maintain their blood
sugar level if they don't do it bad
things will happen to their body and
they might even prematurely die if they
don't take their insulin on tight on
time so let's think about what the
elasticity of demand might look like for
something like insulin so in one column
i'll put price and the other column i
will put quantity so let's say that
insulin right now is going for five
dollars a vial
five dollars a vial we have a group of
diabetics who need insulin and they're
all going to buy the insulin they need
and let's say in this group that turns
out to be
100 vials per week 100 so this is in
vials per week
vials
per week fair enough that's exactly what
they need to do to maintain their
insulin now what happens if the price
changes what happens if the price were
to go down let's say the price were to
go down to one dollar
well what would the quantity be
well they're they're not going to buy
any more insulin they're going to buy
just what they need in order to maintain
their diabetes and remember we're
holding all else equal we're not
assuming any change in expectations of
price they expect price to go up or down
or anything like that so in this case
they'll still just buy 100 vials now
what happens if the price went up a ton
what if happens if the price went to
what happens if it went to 100 a vial
well it would be hard for them but they
need it to survive so it's going to
squeeze out any other expenses that they
need to spend money on and so they still
will buy 100 vials a week and so you
could keep raising price within reason
and they would still buy the same
quantity obviously if you raise it to a
billion dollars then they would just
wouldn't be able to afford it but within
reason they're going to buy a hundred
vials per week no matter what the price
is so this
this is an example of perfect in
elasticity
perfect
perfect in elasticity lasticity
another way so if you think of the
physical analogy that we talked about
with elasticity it's like a brick it
doesn't matter how much within reason
once again any amount of force pulling
or pushing that a human could put on a
brick it's not going to change it's not
going to deform the brick in any way and
likewise any change in price within
reason within reason here isn't going to
change the demand in any way it's
perfectly inelastic and if you want to
do the computation you could look at the
in outlast you could figure out the
demand elasticity for let's say when
you're going from a price of five
dollars to one dollar so the price went
down
by four
and the quantity the quantity changed by
zero so your percent change in quantity
percent
so delta percent percent
percent all right percent change
in quantity is equal to zero and then
your percent is going to be over your
percent change
in price your percent change in price if
you use the averaging method it was four
it would be going down by four over an
average of 250 it'll be a fairly large
number but zero over anything is still
going to be zero so it doesn't matter
what that thing is over here your your
elasticity of demand in this situation
is zero and if you wanted to see what
this demand curve would look like let's
plot it
so this right over here is my price axis
and that is my quantity axis and so no
matter what let's say this is a quantity
of 100 vials per week that's true when
the price is that's true when the price
is five dollars so that's true when the
price is five dollars
they're going to demand 100 100 miles a
week that's true when the price is one
dollar they're gonna demand
a hundred files a week and that's true
if the price is twenty dollars or a
hundred dollars or whatever they're
going to demand they're going to demand
a hundred miles a week and so a
perfectly inelastic demand curve would
look like this
it is a vertical line it doesn't matter
what price you pick they're all the
quantity demanded is always going to be
the exact same thing now let's go to
another extreme so this is perfectly
inelastic you can imagine well what is
perfectly elastic something that changes
a lot if you have a small percentage
change in price and to think about that
let's look at these two vending machines
and you see that they both do sell cans
of coke that's a can of coke there and
that is a can of coke there and let's
say starting off the can of coke let's
say that they cost a dollar in each
vending machine they cost a dollar in
each vending machine
and we're going to assume that this one
remember all else equals so we're going
to assume that we're going to assume
that this vending machine right over
here doesn't change does
not
change so it's just going to be
consistently charging a dollar for a can
of coke and they're sitting next to each
other and it looks like they have a
little coffee machine in between right
over here so let's think about the
demand curve for this for coca-cola in
this vending machine right over here so
let's think about the price and the
quantity so i'll do let me do price
column and quantity demanded so let's
say if the price is a dollar so if the
price is one
if the price is one dollar
then you know just odds are it's going
to get about half of the sales per week
and let's say that ends up being let's
say that ends up being i don't know
let's say that ends up being 100 cans
100 this is in cans per week
cans
per week
now what happens then let me put some
decimals here so this is one dollar the
price is one dollar it sells 100 cans
per week and probably this one would
also sell about 100 cans per week now
what happens if we have a very very
small change in price so if we have if
we change if we go from a dollar instead
of a dollar we we are at
99 cents
99 cents
what's going to happen
so this this remember this machine right
over here is not changing this is we're
talking of our demand curve is for the
quantity of cokes sold from this machine
and the price we're talking about is for
this machine so if this machine is even
a penny cheaper and assuming that you
know people there aren't lines forming
and things like that people are just
always going to go to this machine if
it's easy enough if there's no
difference we do they're always going to
go to this machine so this machine will
be able to get will sell all the cokes
so it's going to sell it's going to sell
200 cokes now what happens if instead of
lowering the price by penny you raise
the price by penny so instead of a
dollar you're at a dollar a dollar one
well now everyone's going to go to the
other vending machine they're going to
say oh we don't need a you know even a
penny out might as well walk to this one
you know assuming everything else is
equal so then they're going to sell
they're going to sell 0. and so what
would the demand curve look like here
well let's plot it out
let's plot it out
so this is the price
this right over this axis right over
here is quantity and this is in cans per
week and so this is zero
this is 100 100 and then this is 200 and
then this is a price of one dollar
that's one dollar so at one dollar
at one dollar the quantity demanded is
100 cans fair enough
now at 99 cents the quantity demanded is
200 cans so 99 cents the quantity
demanded is 200. so 99 cents is right
below that it's 200. so it's right over
there so it's like right right there's a
little bit lower and at a dollar one a
little bit over here the quantity
demanded is zero the quantity demanded
is zero so the demand curve here is
going to look something like
it's going to look something like
is going to look something like that so
it's going to be almost horizontal so
it's going to be approaching perfect
elasticity very small changes in price
end up with these huge changes huge
changes in percent quantity
demanded and i encourage you to work out
the math to see here that you will get a
very large number for elasticity and so
something that is this is approaching
perfect elasticity a truly perfect
elasticity
would be something would be something
that is a horizontal line so in this
case so over here our elasticity of
demand and i'll talk about the absolute
value of it is zero and over here the
absolute value of our elasticity of
demand is infinity because remember it's
percent change in quantity over percent
change in price when you go from either
from one scenario to another over here
your percent change in price is very
small it's roughly about one percent oh
in this scenario right over here
changing the price up or down about one
percent but then you see your quantity
is changing depending on which one
you're looking your quantity is changing
on the order of fifty to a hundred
percent from that one percent change in
price so you have a huge elasticity of
demand here it would be a real it would
actually be a number but as you can
imagine as it becomes more and more
sensitive as quantity demanded becomes
more and more sensitive to percent
change in price this curve is going to
flatten out completely and you will have
an infinite absolute value of your
elasticity of demand